what do you want you I'm here to extend  you an opportunity one last mission you  get your life back  retrieve the asset you go home to your  family or do you have something very  special for sale is how you found it  it's not working so did you want it when  you find it Iranian media has dubbed it  the horror of hamadan droid infantry  units deployed in Iran are used in  warfare toys like this one have been  terrorized in Mexican city of Juarez  they've been taken to see in blood not  bottle cartel as our earth does in these  streets finding do what you have to do  but don't come home without it  let us welcome you to one hands with  some real Mexican hospitality  making droids tricky business that force  freely here in Juarez finish my weapon  [Laughter]  you